hello and welcome to the section on
constant predictors
now the idea of this section is to
explore the simplest possible
predictor and that's the constant
predictor
what constant means here is that instead
of g
theta of x depending on x
g theta of x totally ignores x it always
returns
the same y hat the same prediction
and so we'll just call that theta and
that will be
the parameter that determines the
predictor and the parameter
therefore determines the prediction
and it will be a vector in r m
the purpose of looking at such a simple
predictor
is that it gives us an understanding of
what the loss
means and we will look at a number of
different losses
and be able to get some understanding of
what it means
to have a prediction that minimizes
those particular losses
another way to think about what we're
doing in this section is we're looking
at a linear regression model
where the features are the simplest
possible features
every data element is just
given feature phi of u is equal to 1
which is nice it doesn't depend on you
and of course
we don't even need u
how are we going to do this well we're
going to use erm empirical risk
minimization to fit theta to
the data and because there's no
sensitivity
we're going to have no need for
regularization
the predictor is completely insensitive
so as we'll see different losses lead to
different predictors
so we're going to have data y1 through
yn
each one of those y's will be either a
scalar
or a vector in r m and we'll have a loss
function
which will take two y's
a y hat and a y and return as a real
number
um and i think in every
one of the predictors we analyze today
we're going to have m
is equal to one so all of the y's will
in fact be a scalar
let me write that on the slide m is
equal to one
so our loss function l of y hat and y
quantifies how badly y hat approximates
y
and we've seen a few different losses
so far in this course
so for scalar y we've seen the quadratic
loss
which is y hat minus y squared we've
seen the absolute loss
which is the absolute value of y hat
minus y
we've seen the fractional loss which is
the max
of y hat over y minus one and y
over y hat minus one and that's the
percentage error once we scale it by
100.
of course the fractional loss only
applies when both y and y
are positive numbers
and if we were looking at m greater than
one
when we had a vector y we might look at
the quadratic loss
as the norm squared of y hat minus y
so we're going to choose now a predictor
with no data so our predictor just
returns theta
and we're going to choose the theta to
minimize the empirical risk
and that's going to be the average of
the loss
of theta and y i averaged over all the
data elements
y i for i is 1 up to n
and we will solve it in these particular
cases and in some other cases as well
and we'll see that the
result that you get is actually very
interpretable
now one of the features of losses
that make them tractable that make them
make them make it possible for us to
determine either analytically or
numerically
exactly what the
optimal theta is is convexity
so here we have a function f mapping
from rk
to the real numbers so this is a real
valued function
on a k k-dimensional euclidean space
and such functions we're going to call
convex
if they satisfy the following inequality
and that is that for all points w and z
in rk and for all alpha
in the interval 0 to 1 if we evaluate
f at alpha w plus 1 minus
alpha z that's less than or equal to
alpha times f of w plus one minus alpha
times f of z now this
inequality this expression
has a nice meaning let's look at it
here we have two points w and z
and they live in a k dimensional space
and what this this like this
expression does alpha w plus one minus
alpha d
z is it's a parameterization of the line
segment
connecting z to w
and when alpha is zero well then
alpha w plus one minus alpha z is just z
when alpha is one
it's just w
when alpha is a quarter
we find that alpha w plus one minus
alpha z is exactly one quarter of the
way
along the line from z to w
so this expression alpha w plus one
minus alpha z
is called a convex combination of w and
z
and it's simply a way of parameterizing
the line segment
between two points on the right hand
side of this expression
you'll notice we have a very similar
convex combination
but this is of two real numbers f of w
and f of z and so we're parameterizing
the line segment in one dimension from f
of w
f c now what this means
is the following if my point
w let's say
at point one
and my point z is say at point eight
well then f of w is somewhere over here
and f of z is somewhere over here
and this inequality
means that this line segment
lies above
the function
and if for any two points that i pick z
and w the line segment joining
the
corresponding points on the curve lies
above
the curve itself then such a function is
called convex
over here on the right we see an example
where that fails
here are two points
here is the line segment we can see
that it falls underneath
the graph of the function and so this is
not a convex function
so this means that the function has to
curve upwards
another way to say that it has positive
curvature it has to curve upwards
everywhere
now if we have a differentiable function
well convexity can be expressed in terms
of the curvature directly the curvature
of a differentiable function is the
second derivative
and so this expression is exactly
equivalent to
the requirement that the second
derivative of f
at all points w has to be greater than
or equal to zero
and then another way of characterizing
it as well and that is to look at the
first derivative
of the function f and a function is
convex
if and only if its first derivative
is non-decreasing in other words as you
increase w
then the gradient of f can't decrease
that's true those two conditions for
derivatives
are true for functions
from the reals to the reals
and in particular the second condition
that the second derivative has to be
non-negative
can be generalized in a straightforward
way
to functions on rk but we won't need
that here
it's also worth pointing out that the
notion of convexity
defined by this inequality doesn't
have any requirements that the function
be differentiable
and it's quite reasonable to look at
functions
which have kinks in them
and which are so this is a function
which is
which is linear on a region linear on
another region
and then has a curve for the third part
and that's still a convex function it's
simply not
differentiable at this point or at this
point
now convexity has a is a very important
property when one is trying to solve
minimization problems or more general
optimization problems
and this is for this following property
that if i've got a differentiable
function
then a point w is the minimum
of that function if and only if the
gradient of f
at w is equal to zero
and the when you read this expression
it's tempting to confuse this
with similar expressions that you've
seen before in your calculus class
where one is trying to find the minimum
or the maximum of a function
and one looks for stationary points
now the trouble with stationary points
is that they might be a minimum they
might be
a local minimum they might be a local
maximum
well it might be a saddle point or
something else in higher dimensions
here this is not
just a local minimum this is a global
minimum
this is the true meaning of the word
minimize not the colloquial meaning of
the word minimize
this is w that actually finds the global
minimum
of the function f and so one can find
the global minimum
simply by looking for points where the
derivative is zero
now for convex functions on the reals
so that is one dimensional complex
functions
we can characterize explicitly
conditions
under which we have a minimum point now
let's look at that
let me plot such a function
and here i have a function which has
a point which is not differentiable but
yet that point is clearly the minimum
now i can't simply take the derivative
because the function is not
differentiable there
however for a convex function there's
always
a left-hand derivative and a right-hand
derivative
what that means is that if i look at
this point w
there's a slope to the right
and a slope to the left and this slope
to the left
is labeled f dash minus
of w and this slope to the right is
labeled f
dash plus of w they're defined in a way
very similar to the way we usually
define derivatives
this left hand slope is the limit
as t tends to zero of the slope f of w
plus t minus f of w divided by t
but we're allowed to take the limit only
over negative
t and similarly the right hand slope
is a limit taken only over positive t
now in terms of these two
derivatives the left hand and the right
hand derivative
w is a minimum if and only if
the left hand derivative is less than or
equal to zero
and the right-hand derivative is greater
than or equal to zero
even if f is not differentiable we will
have both a left-hand derivative and a
right-hand derivative and so this is a
condition we can use for
any convex function f
if the function is derivative if the
function is differentiable
well then its left hand derivative and
its right hand derivative
will both be the same the slope will be
the same whether we approach the point
from the left hand side or from
the right hand side and both of these
will equal the usual derivative
for a simple example we might look at
the absolute value function
looks like that and we can see that if i
look at the point
w is equal to zero well then
f dash minus of zero is minus one
and f dash plus of zero is one clearly
the left hand derivative is negative
is negative and the left and the right
hand derivative is positive
and therefore w is a minimum
now for many of the loss functions of
interest in machine learning
the loss function itself is a convex
function
of the prediction y-hat certainly the
ones we saw
on the previous two slides all of those
loss functions are convex in the
prediction
it's also true that if you take a convex
function
and another convex function and add them
up
well then the sum of those two convex
functions is itself convex
and if i scale a convex function by a
positive number
well then i get another convex function
and as a result i can take the
average of all of the convex functions
in the empirical risk l
of theta and get another convex function
so the empirical risk is a convex
function
of theta and so by using the optimality
conditions on the previous slide
we can characterize exactly when theta
minimizes
the empirical risk
all we have to do is look at the
left-hand derivative and the right-hand
derivative
and check whether they have the
appropriate sign and that will tell us
when theta is a minimum
so first let's look at the simplest case
the case of square loss
of course this function is convex but
it's also differentiable
then the loss l of y hat and y is the
norm of y hat minus y
squared in the case of a scalar k y
and y hat that's just the square of y
hat minus y
and the empirical risk is just the mean
square error one over n
sum over i theta minus y i
squared because here we have constant
predictor g theta of x is just equal to
theta
now this is a simple least squares
problem we can simply differentiate the
objective with respect to theta
and we'll find that the optimal theta is
one on n times the sum over i of y i
which is the average of the y eyes
this is uh the best constant predictor
when we're using the square loss
it's the average or the mean of the data
the resulting mean square error is the
variance of the data
here's an example here i have
a bunch of data points one here one here
one here and
the mean of those data points is given
by
this red line which is about 1.12
something like that if i plot the loss
function as a function of theta
this is this curve here
and the minimum of that curve is exactly
at the mean
this loss function is a sum of is an
average of the square loss
applied to each of those different
points
so we've actually constructed this loss
function
by taking 1 on n times the sum of 1 2
3 4 5 6 7
square functions each of the form theta
minus
y i squared
now let's look at the absolute loss case
here we have the app the loss function l
of y hat y is the absolute value of y
hat minus y and so the empirical risk is
the mean absolute error
now for this we've got
an empirical risk which is the average
of a bunch of absolute value functions
it's certainly a convex function
because the loss the absolute value of y
hat minus y
is convex and y hat
it's piecewise linear but it's not
smooth it's not differentiable every
point it has
kink points at the data values and we
will actually see that the theta that
optimizes
this empirical risk the minimum the
theta that minimizes the empirical risk
is the median of the data
and this is a very reasonable way of
making an approximation of the data
so here it's the same set of data points
and what we can see is that this
function
is actually piecewise linear if we look
at these points right here these are
kink points
let me make those a little bigger these
are kink points
in the graph between those points
the graph is a straight line and at
those points there's an abrupt
change in the derivative of the function
the here we have one two three four
five six seven data points and so
if we sort those data points the median
is the fourth data point
it has three points to the left and
three points to the right
and that gives us this median value
right there which is precisely
the value which minimizes
the empirical risk
let's take a look at this a little bit
more closely we want to actually
first of all define the median and
that's
not quite as straightforward as it at
first appears
if we have an odd number
of data points well then the median is
the middle point if we have an even
number of data points
well then we have to allow ourselves the
possibility
that any to
any point which is
which has half of the data points to the
left and half of the data points to the
right
might be reasonably considered at median
let's first of all write that down
mathematically and then
do the analysis
so the simplest uh
let's look at an example first suppose
we have
data y1 through yn
if n is odd
then the median is simply the middle
point which is y
n plus 1 over 2 and that's
completely well defined if n
is even well then we say theta is a
median
if theta is anywhere between y and on 2
and y ni 2 plus 1. the median is not
unique
so if i have
these four data points
minus 3.3 minus 1.7
0.4 and well there's the three data
points and the median is just the middle
one which is minus 1.7
if i have four data points so i add a
new data point at 4.9
well then the median is any number
between -1.7 and 0.4
now to characterize the median precisely
we will define
two quantities the first of which is
going to be called
n1 and that's a function of theta
and it is the number of data points
strictly less than theta
the second one is n2 it's also a
function of theta it's the number of
data points strictly greater
than theta and then theta is a median of
the data
if n one divided by n
the fraction of data points strictly
less than theta
is less than or equal to half and then
two divided by n
the fraction of data points strictly
greater than theta
is also less than or equal to one-half
now if theta is not equal to a data
point
then the number of
data points strictly less than theta and
the number of data points strictly
greater than theta are actually
related of course they add up n1 plus n2
is going to add up to n and so both of
these conditions collapse now to one
condition
which is just that n1 divided by n is a
half
the number of data points less than
theta is a half
implies that the number of data points
greater than theta is a half
if theta is equal to a data point
well then we need two conditions not
just one condition to characterize the
median
because there may be a certain number of
data points equal to the value of theta
now we can use this characterization in
order to show
that the median or a median because the
median is in general not
unique minimizes
the empirical risk when we're using the
absolute loss
and it is the case that
there may be more than one minimizer of
the risk and that every one of those
risks those minimizers
is a median and conversely that
you pick any median of the data
and that will be a minimizer of
the risk how do we see this well
let's first of all just assume the data
is sorted
so we'll have y1 less than or equal to
y2 all the way up to yn
of course that doesn't make any
difference to the problem it doesn't
change the
empirical risk because the empirical
risk is just the average of the loss
evaluated at those points so we can
order them any way we want to
let's evaluate the empirical risk the
empirical risk is the sum over the data
of the absolute value of
theta minus y i
or divided by 1 on n for those data
points
for which theta is less
than y i that is
the absolute value of theta minus y i is
minus theta minus y i
for those data points where theta is
greater than y
i the absolute value of theta minus y i
is just theta minus y i
so we'll split up that sum into those
two categories
so first of all we sum
over the points for which
y i is less than theta those are the
first
n one data points
and then we sum over the points for
which
y i is greater than theta and those are
the last
in two data points there may be some
other data points
at which theta is equal to y i
those contribute zero because the loss
at those points
is zero and so they don't enter into
this sum
if there aren't any such data points
theta is not equal
to a data value well we can
differentiate this
sum differentiating this with respect to
theta is easy
we get n1 on n minus
n two on n
um however we actually need to find
the minimum point and it may be that the
minimum point of this function l of
theta
is at a pink point at a point where the
function is not differentiable
and that may or may not be the case we
may be in the case where the function
looks like this
in which case the minimum is any point
here or we may be in the case
where the function
has a kink in it in which case the
minimum
is there now if we're at a
point if we're at the case where there's
a kink in the function and the minimum
is at the kink
well now we can't simply
differentiate l of theta and so what we
need to do is look at
the left hand and right hand derivatives
to do this we will assume
first of all that theta is just to the
left of a data point
now when theta is just to the left of a
data point
well suddenly there's no possibility
that there's a data point
at theta and so
n1 and n2 are related because
n1 plus n2 equals n and so
this i can evaluate this
expression knowing
that n2 is equal to n minus n1
and then i can differentiate it and when
i do that
i end up with this expression right here
for l dash minus of theta
and i can do exactly the same thing when
i'm looking at the right-hand derivative
and when i look at the right-hand
derivative i can
substitute in again n1 plus n2 is equal
to n
because i know theta is not at a data
point and here
we've chosen to eliminate n one rather
than eliminating n2
and so we get a slightly different
expression
for l l dash plus
now theta's optimal means that l dash
minus of theta is less than or equal to
zero
and l dash plus of theta is greater than
or equal to zero
and those two conditions come
immediately
from here two n 1 on n minus 1 is less
than or equal to 0
means n 1 on n is less than equal to
half
conversely the right hand condition
becomes n 2 on n is less than or equal
to half
and those are the precise conditions
under which
theta is the median
and so we've shown that theta is the
median is equivalent to cedar
minimizing the empirical risk
so now i want to turn to a different
loss function and we're going to
construct it using
this function the tilted absolute value
function
and what it is is it's a parameterized
family of functions it has a parameter
tau in it
which must be between zero and one and
then it gives us a penalty function we
will use it to
penalize the difference between the
prediction y
hat and the actual y so u here
corresponds to y hat minus y
and we're going to have p of u be either
minus tau times u when u is less than
zero
or one minus tau times u when u is
greater than or equal to zero
and it is exactly what the name suggests
when tau is a half it's like an absolute
value function
just scaled so it's equal to one-half
the absolute value function if we
increase tau
then we see that it tilts
and it is larger for negative u
then for positive u and if we decrease
tau
then it tilts the other way and it
becomes larger
for positive u and for negative u and
there's a nice expression for it
which is explicit in voice the cases
it's a half minus tau times u
plus one half multiplied by the absolute
value of u
now if we use it as a loss function well
then we've got the tilted
absolute loss which is
the loss of y hat y is p tau
of y hat minus y and so
the risk will be the average tilted
absolute loss
now this function l of theta the risk
is convex and it's piecewise linear
because
the tilted absolute loss is a convex
piecewise linear
function of y hat and when we take the
average of such functions we get another
one
and it turns out that it has kink points
at the data
y1 through yn
now if tau is less than a half well that
means that when y
hat is less than y
we are going to have a small value of
the penalty function
compared to when y hat is greater than y
and so it's going to be worse to
overestimate than to underestimate we're
going to prefer
to make underestimates for a tower
greater than a half we prefer
to overestimate and it's worse
to underestimate and so there are
situations
where one would prefer to make an
overestimate
than an underestimate if we're measuring
the quantity of something dangerous we'd
prefer to overestimate that quantity
rather than underestimate that quantity
and so we'll see that theta is optimal
if it's a tau quantile of the data
and that means that roughly a fraction
of the y's less than
theta is around tau
so here's the empirical risk we have
here
a collection of data points
and the risk function
has kinks in it directly above
the data points
and in between those data points it is
piece y is linear and
so these segments joining the data
points
are straight lines
and the optimal theta
it's it's right here at the data point
it's at 0.5
and this is where tau is 0.25 and we can
see
that this loss function is going to
increase
like this or get steeper this loss
function actually turns out
doesn't get any steeper at all and
because we these are the only data
points that we have in fact we know
that this loss function continues
straight and this loss function
continues straight and we can see
that there's a penalty for
underestimating
a penalty for overestimating and the
penalty for overestimating is
greater than the penalty for
underestimating
so just like we did for the medians we
need to define carefully what a
tau quantile is and then we'll see
that the tau quantiles are the things
that minimize
the empirical risk so for tau between 0
and 1
theta is a tau quantile if
n 1 on n is less than or equal to tau
is less than or equal to 1 minus n 2 on
n so remember n 1
is the number of data points strictly
less than theta
so m 1 on n is the fraction of the data
less than theta and n 2
on n is the fraction of the data
greater than theta and so 1 minus n
2 on n is the fraction of the data less
than or equal
to the predictor y hat or theta
now if theta doesn't equal any of the
data points
well then m1 and n2 are related because
n1 plus n2 is then going to equal
n and so these two inequalities reduce
to one inequality
and uh to actually they're reduced to an
equation
because we have n1 on n is going to be
less than or equal to theta
and the other inequality is going to
reduce to n1 on n is greater is
less than or equal is greater than or
equal to tau
so we'll have two inequalities of the
opposite sign and as a result
the those two inequalities boil down to
tau
is n1 on n the fraction of data points
less than theta is equal to tau
if you're at a data point then you have
to be careful to account for the number
of data points equal to theta
quantiles have names one of them we've
seen already when towers are half is the
median
another one are the quartiles towers a
quarter towers are half times 0.75
the deciles towers 0.1 through 0.9
and the percentiles
let's look at some examples of quantiles
here
we have a plot on the left
we see the tau quantiles
and on the horizontal axis we see tau
we've got five data points four seven
seven
eight and nine let's just mark those
four seven seven
eight and nine and
if we pick
a tau of 0.1
then there's a unique quantile
theta is equal to 4. if we pick a tower
of 0.2
then there's a range
of quantiles between 4 and 7
any number between 4 and 7 is a 0.2
quantile
here at 0.5
the corresponding 0.5 quantile
is 7.
now the tau quantile
minimizes the empirical risk when you
have tilted absolute loss
and this is exactly like the argument we
used in the case of the median
let's say this precisely we'll say that
theta
minimizes the empirical risk if and only
if
it's one of the tau quantiles and here
the empirical risk is defined with the
tilted absolute loss
and the tilted absolute loss has
parameter tau in it
and the argument goes exactly the same
way
we assume the data is sorted and then
the loss
has n terms in it each one has the form
p tau theta minus y i
but those expressions for p tau depend
on whether theta
is less than y i or c 2 is greater than
y i
and so we split that sum up into terms
for which theta is less than y i
and the terms which theta is greater
than y
i now if theta's not equal to a data
value we can just immediately
differentiate this with respect to theta
and we find this nice expression
we can
evaluate this to find out whether or not
we're at a point where
theta is l dash of theta is zero
but the if we're looking to check
whether or not
we have a minimum we know that this
function l
is not differentiable and so that's not
a sufficient test for minimum
for c to be optimal instead we need to
look at the left and the right
derivatives
and we do the same trick as before we
consider a point
and in order to evaluate uh
the derivative the left hand derivative
we'll evaluate the left-hand derivative
at a point c to slightly to the left of
the point
if we move slightly left to the point
then n1 doesn't change
but n2 does because n2 increases
by the number of points actually at
that minimum and so we eliminate n2 from
the equation since we know that n1
plus n2 is equal to n and that gives us
this expression here for l dash prime of
theta
l dash minus f theta to evaluate
the right hand derivative we move
slightly to the right
when we move slightly to the right we
know
we know again we uh we know
n2 but we don't know n1 because n1
depends
on the number of points at the minimum
and so we eliminate n1 we know n1 plus
enter is n
and we get a nice expression for l dash
plus
of theta then to check for optimality we
have to check that l dash minus theta is
less than or equal to zero
and now that's plus of theta is greater
than equal to zero which gives us
the inequalities that
define the median
let's look at one more case this is the
fractional loss case
now the fractional loss is this loss
right here
the loss of y hat y is the maximum of y
hat divided by y minus 1 and y divided
by y hat minus 1
which has this nice expression as the
exponential
of the absolute value of the difference
between the logarithms minus 1.
and it's this function
it's curved here we are in the case
where y is two and we're looking at y
hat if y is two and y hat is two and a
half
well then y hat is twenty-five percent
more than y
if y is 2 and
we're looking at a y hat of 1
well
uh then we have that
y is a hundred percent more than y hat
and obviously as y hat tends to zero
the percentage more that y is then y
hat is going to tend to infinity
now the empirical risk is therefore the
average of the fractional loss
this is a convex function because the
fractional loss
is convex as we can see from the plot
and we're going to call the theta that
minimizes l
of theta the fractional middle of y 1 to
y and that's actually not
a standard term but it's convenient
this is a plot of the empirical risk as
a function
of theta there are
in fact kinks in this plot they can be
quite hard to see
but they lie exactly above the data
right here
and here and here but the function is
not piecewise linear
between any two kinks it is curved
the data is right here and we can see
that there is a minimum
this is the fractional middle that's
marked in red
that is uh doesn't occur at a data point
in this segment right here is actually a
curved
segment that has a minimum right there
and we go through exactly the same kind
of analysis before we split
the data into data points less than
theta and data points greater than theta
that gives us two
sums
for one of the sums we end up with one
of the expressions in the fractional
loss
and for the other sum we end up with the
other expression in the fractional loss
we can collect all the terms involving
one at the beginning
and so then we'll end up with an
expression like this
now if we're at a theta between two
particular
data points y k and y k plus one
then l dash of theta is easy to evaluate
we simply look at this expression we
have
differentiate it with respect to theta
and we have this expression
right here now because
the empirical risk is convex then
the gradient is going to be an
increasing function of theta and all we
need to do
to find the minimum is to find out where
the gradient
crosses zero so we go through all the
data points one at a time
looking at k till we find uh
until we find one of the k's such that
when we evaluate this derivative here
at the beginning of the interval at y k
we have
a derivative which is less than or equal
to zero and when we evaluate that
derivative
at the other end of the interval at y k
plus one
we have a derivative which is greater
than equal to zero
then we found the interval in which
the optimal theta lies and then we can
look at that derivative and
set it to zero and solve to find the
corresponding theta
and that gives us this nice expression
right here
for the optimal theta so the procedure
to find that theta is first we have to
find
k we have to find k
such that this expression
here is uh
less than or equal to zero
when we evaluate it at t two is y k and
it's greater than or equal to zero when
we evaluate it at theta is yk plus one
and then we just use this formula
to give us the optimal theta
let's summarize the simplest predictor
is a constant
it's y hat is theta
different losses give you different
thetas um
when you apply empirical risk
minimization
and for some common losses you actually
get well-known predictors
the square loss the predictor is the
mean
the absolute loss gives you the median
and the tilt of the absolute loss gives
you the quantile
it's worth also me pointing out at this
point that even though this section
had quite a lot of algebra and
technicalities in it
the technicalities in the algebra don't
really matter
what matters here is the
interpretation of the losses and the
interpretation
of the results that they give you
you should know that when you're going
to
do machine learning with a square loss
you're going to get an answer
which corresponds to the mean
if you do use the absolute loss you're
going to get something corresponding to
the median
and have some intuition about how those
things
behave in particular we know that
the median is kind of insensitive to the
position of outliers
whereas the mean is very sensitive
to the position of outliers
the tilted absolute loss is very useful
because very often we really do want an
estimate
which is
preferentially underestimating or
preferentially
overestimating the true why